Let's draw a square.
It is not drawn ideally, but it is
acceptable square experience. And of course
one of the things we know about the square,
is that all of its sides will have the same length.
If the length of this side is x,
then all of them,
each of them will be x length.
We also know it will be
makes angles, so it's a square.
Now the question I want to ask,
is whether the length of the sides of the square
is direct to his face?
And I recommend pausing the video and thinking about it
whether the lengths of the sides of a square
are directly proportional to the face of the square?
To think about it, let's draw
a small table here.
The length of the country
will be given as x,
this will be x, then
I'll have another column, I can draw
this a little better, let me
I use this tool, here,
I will draw two columns
right here,
and then here I will put the face.
Face ... How much will be the face?
The face will be one of the sides raised in a square,
you can see it as the width of the height,
so we will have x by x or x square.
Let's simply choose multiple values ​​for x
and then determine what the person will be.
If x is equal to 1,
the face will be 1 in 1,
which is also 1.
If x is equal to 2,
the face will be 2 in 2,
which is equal to 4.
If x is equal to 3,
the face will be 3 by 3,
which is equal to 9. I can go on,
but I think that's enough. There are enough points,
to consider whether the length of the country is directly proportional to the person,
or is the person directly proportional to the length of the country?
One way you can view
the proportionality, is whether relations between
the length of the country and the person concerned
are always the same. So we want to look
the relationship between the length of the country and the person,
or the face and length of the country, as they are always constants.
The face and the length of the country, let me do it
as two separate ...
I'll make one extra column here.
Let's draw an extra column here,
behold, let us look at this attitude,
the attitude of the person
to the length of the country.
Here the ratio is 1 on 1,
which equals 1.
This seems acceptable.
For these follow the attitude of the person
and the length of the country is 4 on 2,
4 on 2, which is equal to 2.
I do not even have to move on to the third one.
I can say that this attitude,
the face on the length of the country will be equal to 3.
Note that every time I get a different value.
This is not equal to a constant, I do not
a constant relationship between face and length of the country,
which shows us that these two,
length of the country and person are not directly proportional.
No, they are not straightforward.
And if you look at it, it is quite logical that
the relationship will actually be equal to
the actual length of the country that will change
depending on the length of the country and that's because
we lift a square.
You literally raise x to square,
if you have x here,
this will be x square,
and the ratio will be x of a square on x,
which of course will always be
equal, x is x, divided by x,
this will always be equal to x,
we see it here.
But it is definitely not straightforward.